okay adam when are you ready
let's start the engine
if the uk economy is to maneuver through
the supply chain crisis it's going to
need people like adam retraining as an
hgv driver the most in-demand job in
business well i worked for amazon
i did their multi-drop driving
uh just love being on the road it will
almost double my yearly salary what i'm
on now like if i find the right place so
you know it's definitely well worth it
and which means i can
you know treat my kids more
adam's one of hundreds of drivers
passing through britain's largest
training company every month attracted
by rising wages driven by huge demand
i think it's going through the roof this
drivers i know that are working for
companies and been there for years
they've had two or three pay risers this
year without even asking for it because
it's had to adjust to supply and demand
there's people newly qualified drivers
who run over 35 000 pounds a year now at
some companies
new drivers are filling a shortage
accelerated in the past two years by
brexit which denied visas to european
drivers and the pandemic which paused
testing for hgv licenses
since 2019 the number of hgv drivers in
the uk reduced by almost 50 000 of those
there are 14 000 fewer eu drivers but
the biggest loss was of 31 000 uk based
drivers who've left the road in the last
two years
put off perhaps by long hours and wages
that until recently were falling
relative to other low-skilled jobs
the driver shortage is a live test of
one of the government's central
arguments for brexit which was that
cutting the number of lower skilled
european workers here would increase
opportunities and wages for british
workers so they say the answer is to
train and hire at home
even if they're right that still leaves
shortages today nando's and mcdonald's
have had to close restaurants and cut
menu items and if even the high street
giants are struggling try being a
smaller business farsan and leicester
make food and snacks for restaurants and
caterers it's really frustrating that we
on one side can't get product and then
on the other side can't get product out
so when we do have product in stock so
it's yeah it's a bit of a nightmare to
be in that now that the sales are there
or while the orders are there we can't
actually fulfill them the government's
recipe is for a home-grown solution
helped by workers coming off furlough
next month but without the drivers who
keep the economy moving the recovery may
be on ice paul kelso sky news in
leicester